here we got this is a this is
interesting this is a segment from wait
I'm sorry I'm sorry can I say one quick
Sports thing sure because it's a big
Sports weekend man I mean there was Indy
car there was NASCAR yeah there was F1
car F2 car F3 car there was fights more
faster it was football football or so
many goddamn Sports I don't know where
to begin so so many men going after each
other I couldn't I didn't know we're
just happy I have my Sundays back yeah
wake up
right on the couch football all day yeah
other TV Indie Dawn till Dusk
trading my fantasy players I tell my
wife I say Sunday is not on the calendar
anymore
no girls allowed yeah in this room you
want to do something on Sunday no
not with me
I'm watching football I'm watching the
men play with the ball I can't care I
try I don't know hard no shame I will
never give a [ __ ] about football and no
shame in it
I'm sorry but I will say this though
what I commend you for trying thank you
yeah I'm gonna try a couple more times
probably yeah you know I'll watch the
Super Bowl or if there's a
we're at the top of the Season I'm gonna
try a couple more times I'm gonna watch
the end I will I'll watch the last time
I will watch the last game that's fair
and if there's another big big one in
between yeah you know
a rivalry or uh Conference Final or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah I'll watch those
nice okay but as far as regular season
games go I just the only thing I give a
[ __ ] about is not losing the TMG League
okay that's what I care about so I will
be checking on Sundays how my team's
doing well here's the sports thing you
can understand what so I've never
watched NASCAR
outside of like highlight Clips here and
there so there's a there's a NASCAR race
and they're interviewing one of the guys
they're like
this is our pole sitter today but he's
out of the race uh tell us what happened
we got a flat tire
[Music]
[Laughter]
I was crying I'm like that just did not
help the case of trying to prove
NASCAR's a sport you know just anything
that can happen to anyone else yeah it
got flat tire took us out of the race
yeah I got tired yeah sorry I thought he
was a flat tire and I just got tired
yeah my podcast ended so I thought I'd
pull off or I got bored yeah just
thought I'd head home
he goes yep uh we got good power but
I don't know it's just just shredding
tires so we had a flat spun us out uh it
gets out of the thing jacks up his car
himself he is fixing it on the side of
the Court yeah yeah I don't know and
then uh then the interviewer goes
do you think you know what do you think
happened to to come on I got a flat tire
yeah thanks he just walks away I'm like
damn
that's
that's a sport right there yeah
something we can all relate to yeah I
hate when that happens yeah yeah man see
that I can care about yeah yeah maybe
you should watch Nascar it's easy yeah
yeah you can just look up from time to
time and then the the order is different
yeah you're like oh that guy's in front
of that guy you look back down exactly
yeah you don't have to know where it
happened you're like it was like one of
those turns you know what I you know
what I really like [ __ ]
I've been watching these uh the untold
documentaries on Netflix yeah they kind
of just jacked the 30 for 30 yeah since
last week yeah yeah which one are you
watching the one I watched was the one
about uh the tennis player Larry fish is
that his name
something fish but the story is about
him basically uh finding out he has a
crazy anxiety disorder yeah and
he like basically makes it to the peak
in his career and is about to play
Federer yeah the most important game
ever of his career and he pulls out
because he's like having panic attacks
and can't do it whoa and so then it's
like it becomes kind of about his
recovery well I like watching tennis
I realize yeah yeah
don't you
ever watch it no nah you just
giving in all your freck guy Tendencies
now yeah tennis golf
yeah I just can't get into football yeah
it's not an elegant sport
wait tennis football is the most frat
guy sport it is yeah no you're
absolutely no you're okay you're not
you're you're leaning into your I feel
like this is your Yacht Club Tendencies
yeah yeah and that's funny because the
the last documentary that I watched last
night was about America's Cup what's
that the sailing race oh goodness that
is the that is the richest bougie of
sport people know what this is but
people don't know what it is yeah I mean
I didn't know the details I know about
it because it used to be uh or they did
it in SF a couple times when I lived
there so like running by the marina you
would see like America's Cup Oracle
yeah see
that right there what yeah he's used to
run by it in San Francisco well like the
like the Embarcadero like it's like the
[ __ ] oh you don't speak Italian to me
you're a well-traveled guy all right
I get it dude you've been on a private
plan it's fine
um that story is crazy though no I'm
sure America won the America's Cup for
132 years in a row
and that's and the documentary is about
the Australian team that won the cup for
the first time in 132 years and so they
interviewed the dude who lost it and
it's just the saddest thing ever because
he yeah cause he broke the American yeah
because he's like yeah I went to the
press conference after and
no one from the New York Yacht Club
showed up so I don't think they like me
very much and he's like 80 years old and
you're just like damn dude well that's
their you can tell it's just haunted him
for his entire life
oh he wasn't 80 when he sailed though no
he's 80 now okay he's old as [ __ ] for
a second I was just even sadder yeah but
I thought the way you phrased that made
me think they had an 80 or they tasked
an 80 year old with keeping up the
tradition yeah yeah it's like they got
no reason to be she's [ __ ] in a
wheelchair yeah rolling around that's
the ships like this that's rolling to
the front pretty [ __ ] oh yo somebody
somebody gets Skipper damn yeah poor guy
but it's a crazy ass story yeah sure
anyways you guys should watch those yo
if we're talking about okay hold up if
sailing is a sport racing cars is
definitely a sport I never said it
wasn't a sport no no I'm just it is a
sport yeah yeah for sure people like to
say racing cars isn't a sport but I'm
like
sailing I'm just thinking about all
these people in the comments being like
dude everyone knows about the America's
sailing stop shaming Cody okay yeah I
mean I feel like that was a little bit
unwarranted what shaming you for liking
sailing I don't like sailing I like that
documentary and I just knew you're just
shaming me because I didn't because you
didn't know about the America's Cup no
I'm shaming you for liking yacht club
stuff
you gotta watch that documentary it's a
great story no I believe it's a great
story but I'm just worried about the
rabbit hole you're falling down
that okay it is it started with you
though I do I'm sure you like bocce ball
too I watch a lot of golf yeah I do yeah
and Tennis is I know it's like yeah it
is kind of like
waspy [ __ ] yeah you're you're falling
down the hole yeah what the [ __ ] is next
dude Cricket Maybe